ciao maryners e benvenuti in un nuovissimo video
so che questo video più o meno l'hanno
già fatto tutti l'avrete già visto ma
ovviamente mancava la mia fantastica
versione sono sicura che ognuno di voi
si ritroverà in queste tipologie e
quindi partiamo subito ci vediamo alla
fine del video como te llamas baby desde
que te vi super che eras pa mi
la solitudine tra noi questo silenzio dentro me
ho un certo languorino cosa potrei mangiare di buono
adesso sì che ragioniamo
mado guarda che punto nero é bellissimo da schiacciare
perfetto lo terrei quasi per
ricordo
ma questa é una ciste la schiaccio o non la schiaccio non dovrei ma chissene frega
adesso una bella stalkerata generale
del mio ex della sua nuova tipa del tipo
che mi piace e siamo a posto
da chi iniziamo sta già con un'altra ma guarda sto
stronzo ne cambia una al giorno
l'ho vista due volte l'ho vista tre
volte l'ho vista sei volte l'ho vista
una volta sola quindi potrei rivederla
corri muoviti che poi ti uccide ma cosa
cadi dalle nuvole si sapeva che
ti tradiva lo sapevamo tutti quanti soltanto tu non lo sapevi
oh guarda che tette
sembrano piú grosse ammazza oh poi sono proprio piú ah forse é il push up
cos'era
oddio ci sono i ladri
ok ma perché va cosí veloce ma a me non viene così uffa
ma poi perché va veloce ma quanta terra si mette
dimmi quando tu verrai vedi la casa pulita è un'altra cosa
altroché comunque l'esame se lo do il 24
devo iniziare a studiare oggi
questo si che é amore
non troverò mai uno che mi ami cosí
ah si non lo sapevi eh si ormai sono già di 7 mesi quindi tra 2 mesi partorisco
è maschio e femmina 2
no amo non puoi capire apparte che sono svaccata sul divano che minchia sto
proprio da dio e praticamente mi sono appena mangiata una parmigiana ti
giuro era piú grossa di me infatti adesso c'ho un pó la pesantezza aspetta un attimo
ho appena tirato un rutto che lasciami perdere
vediamo oscena tremenda improponibile bruttissima basta niente foto
che palle sistemare
ecco dov'era il mio orecchino preferito
chissà dov'é l'altro
ecco la crema ho proprio voglia di
spalmarmi un pó di crema sulle mani
ecco il telefono si dai cazzeggiamo un pó
sei proprio un cretino
no io invece sono a un concerto nel
backstage perché sono amica del cantante
quindi per questo non senti rumore
perché siamo pochi intimi è un mood
molto private se la sará bevuta
eccoci purtroppo arrivati alla fine del
video spero tantissimo che vi sia
piaciuto e che vi siate ritrovati in
queste tipologie fatemi sapere con un
commento qui sotto
in quale di queste scene vi siete
ritrovati maggiormente e soprattutto se
non avete ancora fatto
iscrivetevi al mio canale e cliccate sulla
campanella vicino al tasto d'iscrizione
per ricevere una notifica tutte le
volte che pubblicherò un nuovo video e
ricordatevi anche di seguirmi su tutti
gli altri social instagram facebook ei
tiktok
io vi mando un bacione enorme ci vediamo al prossimo video